neon future sessions we are diving into
the future artificial intelligence
nanotechnology singularity immortality
androids unraveling the mystery of the
brain okay I'm excited to see where
technology and humanity are going to be
converging I've talked to scientists
philosophers writers you know all those
questions are exciting for me to think
about the future is intriguing it's like
a snake shedding its skin I could blame
one person that opened the doorway into
this idea of a utopian nyan future and
that's Ray Kurzweil well a futurist
tries to predict the future and I have a
particular methodology which really does
work I made predictions based on that in
1981 in our in 2014 and we're right on
the money as to where that trend should
be he talks about singularity humanity
and technology will come together to a
point where we will have no idea no idea
what's gonna happen because it's gonna
be so explosive my main thesis is that
information technology not everything
but information technology progresses
exponentially basically doubles in power
every year and that's not intuitive
because our intuition is that progress
is linear and to demonstrate the power
of that if I take 30 steps linearly
that's our intuition one two three four
five I get to 30 if I take 30 steps
exponentially one to four I get to a
billion
your smartphone is a several billion
times more powerful per dollar than the
computer I used when I was a student at
MIT it's also shrinking in size my
smartphone is a hundred thousand times
smaller than that computer it'll be the
size of a blood cell in 25 years makes
sense doesn't it we look around you and
think back when you had to pull your
antenna from your phone to answer that
call from your mom your phones aren't
gonna be embedded inside your ears
it comes in steps so you already have
technologies like oculus rift that gives
you a pretty realistic full-immersion
virtual reality experience car to the
2030s and like to be inside the nervous
system we all have computers that feed
your brain directly from your nervous
system in fact we'll send intelligent
machines through our body augmenting our
immune system basically resisting all
disease that's mind-blowing so we will
in the 2030s be a hybrid of biological
thinking with our biological brain and
non-biological thinking but the
non-biological part is subject to my law
of accelerating of turns meaning it will
double in power every year our
biological thinking is it's fixed go on
to 2045 and the non-biological part of
our intelligence will be a billion times
more powerful than the biological part
and that's such a profound change that
we borrow this metaphor from physics
they call it a singularity meaning we
can't fully understand all the
consequences you can imagine easily a
lot of negative scenarios and you only
have to look at some of all the movies
which are dystopian
where the computers and robots have it
in for us I have a somewhat different
perspective and that I don't think it's
gonna be us versus them because I think
we're gonna merge with these
technologies and we're gonna become
enhanced with these technologies and
that's why we create these tools is to
make ourselves greater we're the only
species that seeks to change ourselves
we basically create these tools to
extend our own reach 1,000 years ago I
couldn't reach that fruit that higher
branch so I fashioned the tool to extend
my physical reach we are going to cereal
and I am a spiritual person
so when ray talks about evolution as a
spiritual process it's intriguing people
use the word God which i think is a
metaphor that means unlimited in
intelligence and love and creativity
beauty and so what happens in evolution
well we see that entities get more
intelligent more creative more beautiful
becoming more godlike
so evolution is a spiritual process
thank you guys for watching and please
be sure to subscribe